welcome to this video on Gil Gil how
this is this is a totally wrong
pronunciation okay we are talking about
a player from Brazil let's see hmm the
set up against the free door isn't that
great actually if he goes for a five can
I do something really creative here like
long castles or something not really the
bishop does not belong here in the free
door okay I need to do something else
maybe I can play for quick development
here on the D farm it's really not my
usual my usual type of position maybe a
three yeah that's really really totally
nothing well I'm sorry about that a
three is a debatable move actually might
be a weakening of my of my Kings side
I am trying to make some use of my
development here and maybe also of the
fact that i have not I have not played
if I yet so nitey for might be a move
if we T if he castles okay he reacted he
reacted to it Bishop d7 I'm going to
develop here maybe night h 4f 5 is also
move okay so if i take here who does
this reply actually isn't this just
winning material black forfeits due to
disconnection it is I mean I mean why if
you don't want to play you can Kiki know
what so resign yeah it was a slightly
slightly weird game but I sort of
stumble into this set up here I answer
in the Trump maybe I should play
differently him I don't know the thing
is that in the philly do I I mean I can
do this but Bishop g5 is not a really
useful move here as we should be seven
there's always ideas like night h5 and
the bishop really does not belong on g5
I wanted to try to avoid that but turn
it's not clear that that this is Queen
85 is a move that probably is not
necessary but ok it's not a problem he
went back night a three yeah I know
Castle this is a bit strange whatever
thinking is that something something
like that might happen something like
this maybe this Queenie for Queen f5 try
to use the fact that I have not played a
form this is just may be equal nothing
terrible happening to both sides but
here I'm just taking yeah view this is
very obvious
Bishop cakes we should s6 also and if he
takes with the Queen I also take him so
the only move that he can play his route
d8 and now he have something like a
queen III maybe and i'm just a pawn up
but he can of course continue it's not
really a position that you need to
resign yeah very early resignation but
what can you do I thought it was
students as in I mean interesting enough
to upload okay hope you liked it anyway
thanks for watching